[music]
>> Serial number 18, day 13, the 2nd of
February, 2016, Tuesday, we have replies
to most common questions asked by
non-Muslims who have some knowledge of
Islam day two.
Serial number 19, you can turn to the
next page.
Day 14, the 3rd of February, 2016,
Wednesday, we have Dawah through social
media.
Serial number 20, day 15, on the 4th of
February, 2016, on Thursday, we have
Dawah to Christians day one.
Serial number 21,
on the 5th of February, 2016, Friday, we
have the rest day with homework.
Serial number 22, day 16 of the Dawah
training program.
Date, 6th of February, 2016, Saturday,
Dawah to Christians day two.
Serial number 23,
day 17,
on
the 7th of February, 2016, Sunday, Dawah
to Christians day three.
Serial number 24, on the 8th of
February, 2016, Monday, we have a rest
day with the homework. Serial number 25,
day 18, the 9th of February, 2016,
Tuesday, we have Dawah to Hindus day
one.
Serial number 26, day 19 of the Dawah
training program, 10th of February,
2016, Wednesday, we continue with Dawah
to Hindus, that is day two.
Serial number 27, day 20,
on the 11th of February, 2016, Thursday,
we have Dawah to Buddhists and followers
of other religions.
Serial number 28 is again on the 12th of
February, Friday, a rest day with the
homework.
Serial number 29, day 21 of the Dawah
training program,
13th of February, 2016, Saturday, we
have Dawah to the atheists.
Serial number 30, day 22, on the 14th of
February, 2016, Sunday, we have
evaluation of techniques of Dawah
related public speaking.
Serial number 31,
15th of February, 2016, Monday, is a
rest day with the homework.
Serial number 32, day 23, 16/2/2016,
Tuesday, we have techniques of handling
question and answer session day one.
Serial number 33, day 24, 17th of
February, 2016, Wednesday, we have
techniques of handling question and
answer session day two.
Serial number 34, day 25, 18th of
February, 2016, Thursday, we have
replies to common questions asked by
non-Muslims about Islam. This is again
the third set of common questions
along with the Shahada session,
inshallah.
Serial number 35,
19th of February, 2016, on Friday, we
have the Friday Jumu'ah prayers rest day
with the homework.
Serial number 36, day 26,
20th of February, 2016, Saturday, we
will start with the team of debating
skills, inshallah.
Serial number 37, day 27 of the Dawah
training program, 21st of February,
2016, Sunday, we have public talks
followed by question and answer session.
The last page.
Serial number 38,
22nd of February, 2016, Monday, is a
rest day with the homework.
Serial number 39, day 28 of the Dawah
training program, 23rd of February,
2016, Tuesday, we have practical
implementation of skills.
Serial number 40, day 29, 24/2/2016,
Wednesday, we have public debates on
Islamic topics.
Serial number 41, day 30,
25/02/2016,
Thursday, we have the theme of setting
up a Dawah organization.
Serial number 42,
26/02/2016,
Friday, we have the rest day along with
the homework.
Serial number 43, day 31, on the 27th of
February, 2016,
Saturday, we have public debates on
Islam and comparative religion. Serial
number 44, the second last day, day 32,
28th of February, 2016,
Sunday, we continue with public debates
on Islam and comparative religion.
And inshallah, on the last day, serial
number 45, day 33, on the 29th of
February, 2016,
Monday,
which is not an off day, not a rest day,
but the participants come, and that
would be the concluding day along with
action planning by the participants,
inshallah.
This was the 33-day schedule along with
the rest days and the homework, it comes
to 45 days of this international Dawah
training program conceived, developed,
and conducted by Dr. Zakir Naik.
Brothers,
now I invite
none other than Dr. Zakir Naik, the
world-famous orator on Islam and
comparative religion. I want you all to
welcome him with THE TAKBIR. DR. ZAKIR
NAIK.
ALHAMDULILLAH. Was-salatu was-salam
A'udhu billahi min ash-shaytani rajim.
Bismillah ar-Rahman ar-Rahim.
I welcome all of you
with the Islamic greeting Assalamu
alaykum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
May peace, mercy, and blessings of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala be on all of you.
I would like to wish again to all of you
Assalamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
Masha Allah.
Allah says in Surah An-Nisa, chapter 4,
verse 56,
that if anyone wishes you
a greeting which is courteous, you have
to wish back more courteously or at
least the same.
And Allah is careful in keeping of
accounts.
It's compulsory that if anyone greets
you, you have to wish back more
courteously or
at least the same.
If someone says Assalamu alaykum, you
have to say Wa alaykum assalam
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
If someone says Assalamu alaykum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh, you have to
say Wa alaykum assalam warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
If you cannot improve it, at least say
it with more expressions. If someone
says Assalamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh, if you cannot improve, SAY
WA ALAYKUM ASSALAM WARAHMATULLAHI
WABARAKATUH.
OKAY?
SO, I wish again to you Assalamu
alaykum.
Masha Allah. So, I made it short so that
you could make it better.
I would like to welcome
all the participants of the
international Dawah training program.
And alhamdulillah,
it's my pleasure
that I'll be with you, inshallah,
for the next 45 days.
And alhamdulillah,
we had hundreds of applications
from
tens
of different countries of the world.
We didn't count, maybe
50, 60 countries.
Out of these applications that we
received,
we have selected 20 from 10 different
countries, alhamdulillah.
From Malaysia,
we have six, alhamdulillah.
From India, we have three,
two from Singapore, one from UK, one
from Indonesia, one from Japan,
one from Nigeria, one from Saudi Arabia,
one from the Netherlands,
and one from Sri Lanka. From 10
different countries, masha Allah, we
have selected
20 participants, and at the outset, I
would like to congratulate all of you
that
you have been selected from
the several hundred applications that we
received, alhamdulillah.
And I pray to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that may accept our efforts,
and may he fulfill
the right intentions
that we have come here for the course.
This session
will be talking
about the rules and regulations,
and I'm sure
that all of you may have got these
notes,
rules and regulations.
Before we dwell into the formal rules
and regulations, first I'll tell you the
informal rules and regulations.
Point number one,
please be sure that all your mobiles
are off.
Whenever you enter this auditorium,
please see to it
that the mobile is off.
It's preferable if it's not even on the
silent mode.
Because even if it's silent mode,
the buzzer can be heard by the sensitive
microphones.
So, that you should keep all your
mobiles off when you enter the
auditorium.
When you go out, you can on and you can
talk to your friends at home if you
want, but when you get back to the
auditorium, please see to it that the
mobile is switched off, not even in the
silent mode.
There were many instructions given to
you
during the orientation
which was taken by brother Kaleem
yesterday, and one amongst them was
there was certain stationery given to
you.
As a policy
all what is given to you normally during
the day and in the starting of the
program
all can be kept in your room.
The only thing that is required is that
you should get a compass box which can
contain the highlighters, the pencil,
the erasers, the sharpener, etc. And you
can get the black color
bag
which can contain your notes.
We have given you four folders
of different colors.
The newer folders
blue, red yellow, green.
So, whenever you get any notes, and if
you want to refer to the notes during
the day, you can put those notes in that
folder, put the folder in the black bag,
and put it We have given you a very
light, thin bag so that you don't
overburden yourself.
So, see to it that you only carry your
black light bag, very light. It's thin
and light, so you don't have to stuff
anything in it. And whenever you get
that bag, see to it that if you're
sitting on my right
while facing the stage, if you're
sitting on the left so, keep
your bag on your left side.
Please.
Left side.
All those who are sitting on my left
when you're facing the stage you're on
the right of the stage keep your bag on
the right side.
Can anyone tell me why I'm telling this?
Ready for the camera.
We are recording.
So
we don't want a shabby look.
So, if your bag get only a small bag
if you're sitting on the right of the
stage, it should be the right hand side
of your chair.
If you're sitting on the left side of
the stage
then it should be on the left hand side
of your chair. And on the table
keep what is required.
The less
your table is cluttered
it will be better for you.
There's no problem in the camera, but
so that you can concentrate better.
We'll be just going through these point
form notes.
And I'll just mention the important
rules and regulations.
These are only the important ones.
The balance ones will follow as we go
through the workshop or the training
program.
>> [music]
[music]
[chant]
>> Muta'al.